Das ist wirklich eine erstaunliche Entdeckung:
Mehr als 4.000 Einzelsterne bilden einen gewaltigen
Sternen-Strom, der in nur rund 300 Lichtjahren
Entfernung von unserem Sonnensystem das Zentrum
der Milchstraße umkreist.
Und das ist - in kosmischen Maßstäben gesehen
- wirklich unsere direkte “Nachbarschaft”.
Hierbei handelt es sich also höchstwahrscheinlich
um eine der massereichsten Sternengruppe in
Sonnennähe.
Warum dieser gewaltige Sternenstrom so lange
unentdeckt blieb und welche Geheimnisse er
über unseren Kosmos verraten kann, Clixoom
Science & Fiction denn hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos - abonniert den Kanal,
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts - herzlich willkommen!
Aufgespürt werden konnte dieser riesige Sternen-Strom
mit Hilfe von “Gaia”, einer Weltraumsonde
der Europäischen Weltraumorganisation, die
im Dezember 2013 ins Weltall gestartet war.
Und Big Data, also riesige Datenmengen, sind
hier, wie immer öfter, der Schlüssel zum
Erfolg.
Ein österreichisches Forschungsteam hat jetzt
diese riesige Datenmenge, die seitdem 2013
angefallen ist, genauer analysiert.
Zu untersuchen waren unter anderem die Geschwindigkeiten,
und das Alter von mehreren Millionen Sternen
in der näheren Sonnenumgebung.
Und dabei wurde Erstaunliches zu Tage gefördert.
Dazu einer der beteiligten Forscher, Stefan
Meingast: “So haben wir diese bisher unerforschte
Gruppe identifiziert, deren Sterne alle mit
gleicher Geschwindigkeit in die gleiche Richtung
fliegen, gleich alt sind und die Eigenschaften
eines durch Gezeitenkräfte verformten Sternhaufens
aufweist.”
Das wirklich Besondere an dieser Entdeckung
ist, dass dieser Sternen-Strom quasi direkt
an der Erde vorbeifließt.
Das kann man umgangssprachlich tatsächlich
so formulieren, denn in kosmischen Maßstäben
ist die Distanz der nächsten Sterne von wohl
326 Lichtjahren wirklich ein “Klacks”.
Laut dem Forschungsteam ist diese Entdeckung
eine Premiere, denn vergleichbare Sternenströme
konnten bislang nur im fernen Halo, also im
äußeren Bereich der Galaxie, aufgespürt
werden.
Dazu einer der Forscher, João Alves: „Dinge
in der Nähe unseres Heimatplaneten zu finden,
ist sehr hilfreich.
Denn so ist deren Ansicht weder zu schwach
noch zu verschwommen, um analysiert zu werden.
Der große Traum aller Astronomen!“.
Und die Fachleute haben in ihrer Studie noch
mehr Details beschrieben.
Demnach haben sich die Sterne des Stroms wohl
vor etwa einer Milliarde Jahre gebildet.
Der Sternenstrom selbst erstreckt sich über
hunderte Lichtjahre; Schätzungen zufolge
ist er etwa 1305 Lichtjahre lang… Die Sterne
dieser Gruppe verteilen sich also quasi über
den ganzen Himmel, wenn man es von der Erde
aus betrachtet.
Und genau das erklärt auch, warum der Sternenstrom
erst jetzt entdeckt werden konnte.
Laut des Forschungsteams aus Österreich waren
einzelne Sterne davon nämlich bereits bekannt.
Doch niemand hatte den Zusammenhang zwischen
ihnen bislang erkennen können.
Dies haben nun die präzisen Messungen möglich
gemacht.
Doch selbst “Gaia” hat noch Luft nach
oben, denn selbst sie hat Probleme damit,
lichtschwache Objekte zu erfassen.
So konnten bislang nur 200 Sterne des neu
entdeckten Stroms identifiziert werden.
Doch das Forschungsteam ist sich sicher: Mindestens
4.000 zusammenhängende Sterne bilden diesen
Strom.
Dafür spricht laut der Experten beispielsweise
die Tatsache, dass sie sich gemeinsam bewegen.
Somit würde es sich bei dieser Entdeckung
tatsächlich um eine der massereichsten Sternengruppen
in Sonnennähe handeln.
Die Nähe zu uns sei zufällig und habe sich
einfach so ergeben - unter anderem durch die
Bahnen unseres Sonnensystems und des Sternen-Stroms
rund um das Galaxie-Zentrum.
Dennoch sind auch die Expertinnen und Experten
selbst über ihre eigene Entdeckung durchaus
überrascht.
Dazu Alves: “In der Nähe befindliche Scheibenströme
zu identifizieren, ist wie das Suchen nach
der sprichwörtlichen Nadel im Heuhaufen.
Astronomen haben diesen neuen Strom schon
lange betrachtet, da er den größten Teil
des Nachthimmels bedeckt, aber sie erkennen
erst jetzt, dass er da ist.
Er ist riesig und bewegt sich schockierend
nahe an der Sonne.”
Gigantische Sternhaufen, die aus Sternen verschiedenen
Alters und Größe bestehen, sind übrigens
nicht selten.
Auch in der Milchstraße gibt es davon sehr
viele.
Der Großteil davon ist noch jung; nur einige
Millionen Jahre alt.
Weiter außen dagegen, im Halo, existieren
auch massereiche Sternenshaufen, sie schon
seit Milliarden Jahren existieren.
Diese wurden im Laufe der Zeit zu Sternenstömen
auseinandergezogen - Graviatationskräfte
sorgen dafür.
Übrigens gehen wir auch davon aus, dass die
Sonne vor etwa 4,5 Milliarden Jahren in einem
Sterne-Haufen entstanden ist.
Ihre “Geschwister”, also die Sterne dieser
Gruppe, werden seitdem von vielen Forschungsteams
weltweit gesucht.
Denn seitdem haben sie sich wohl über das
ganze Milchstraßensystem verteilt.
Experten und Expertinnen sind jedenfalls optimistisch,
dass mit Hilfe von “Gaia” weitere faszinierende
Sternen-Ströme entdecken werden.
Zudem wollen sie endlich im Detail verstehen,
wie Galaxien entstehen und Gravitationskräfte
in diesem Zusammenhang wirken.
Die Hauptreihe der Sterne einfach erklärt.
Dafür hier kicken, anschauen und Raumzeit
Vlog der Zukunft abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!